SERVICES.
US SENATOR UMBERG'S S. R. EIGHT
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
SO WE WILL NOT BE HEARING THAT
RESOLUTION TODAY.
WE WILL BE TAKING ACTION ON
THREE BILLS. ONE OF WHICH CENTER
WORKS IS ON CONSENT.
AND WE WILL.
GO AHEAD.
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM.
WE WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A SENATOR JACKSON HERE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL.
TWO EIGHT ZERO WELCOME SENATOR
JACKSON.
AND YOUR WITNESSES WE ASK THAT
WOULD ASSIST KEEPER TESTIMONY TO
TWO TO THREE MINUTES PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
OF I GUESS MEMBERS I SIT ON THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL -- FIRST --
LET ME -- INDICATOR -- THAT I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS AND APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN.
ASSISTING ON THIS MEASURE.
NO THIS IS A BILL THAT REALLY
JUST -- BASICALLY TRIES TO
FULFILL THE ADAGE IS A STITCH IN
TIME SAVES -- NINE THIS IS S. B.
TWO AT THE DIGNITY AT HOME ACT
WHICH SEEKS TO ALLOW MORE
SENIORS AND DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
TO AGE IN PLACE.
AND STAY IN THEIR OWN HOMES
THROUGH THE USE OF HOME
MODIFICATIONS.
THAT SIMPLY REDUCE THE RISK OF
FALLING. ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE
EVERY DAY IN CALIFORNIA TURNED
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE WE ARE
NOW AN AGING STATE.
WHAT IS SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS
A NEGATIVE BIRTH RATE STATE?
AND AS A RESULT -- WE ARE AGING
IS A POPULATION IN NEED TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE REALITIES
THAT TAKE PLACE.
AS ONE AGESIN TURN SIXTY FIVE
YEARS OF AGE.
SENIORS -- ARE MORE LIKELY TO
FALL OBVIOUSLY IN SERIOUSLY
INJURE THEMSELVES AND LET'S SAY
A TWO YEAR OLD WHO BOUNCES BACK
AND HAS NO CLUE THAT THEY'VE
JUST HURT THEMSELVES BECAUSE
FRANKLY.
THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO HURT
THEMSELVES WITH THE FALL THAN
SOMEONE WHO IS AGING AND
SUFFERING THROUGH THERE.
THE RAVAGERS OR THE THE
CHALLENGES OF OF THAT AGING
EXPERIENCE. 33% OF ALL FALSE
AMONG OLDER INDOOR ADULTS
INVOLVE HAZARDS AT HOME. ONE
THIRD OF THE FALLS IT'S SENIORS
EXPERIENCE IS AS A RESULT OF A
FALL AT HOME DUE TO THINGS LIKE.
POOR LIGHTING LOOSE CARPET A
LACK OF SAFETY EQUIPMENT THINGS
LIKE GRAB BARS STAIR RAILS HIGH
TOILETS FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY ARE A PARTICULAR RISK. 80%
OF THE FALLS HAD HAPPEN TO
INFILTRATE HOME HAPPEN IN THE
BATHROOM.
SO THIS BILL DOES TWO THINGS TO
HELP SENIORS AND THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES MAKE THEIR HOME
SAFER.
AND A PLACE THAT WILL
ACCOMMODATE THEM FOR YEARS TO
COME FIRST.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
THE ISSUE GRANTS TO OUR AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING. FOR INJURY
PREVENTION SERVICES IN THE HOME
THIS IS THE STATION TIME.
THESE GRANTS CAN BE USED TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS AROUND THE HOME
THINGS THAT I JUST MENTIONED
WHICH ARE CAUSES OF FALSE THINGS
LIKE POOR LIGHTING.
THINGS LIKE ADDING GRAB BARS OR
ROOM -- JUST SIMPLY NAILING DOWN
CARPET THE PEOPLE WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY THINK TO DO.
SMALL IMPROVEMENTS LIKE THIS
FRANKLY CAN MAKE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN.
OUR AGING IN PLACE AND
EXPERIENCING A POTENTIAL FUTURE
BEING INSTITUTIONALIZED.
WE HAVE WE DO NOT HAVE ADEQUATE
HOME FACILITIES NOW FOR OUR
AGING POPULATION.
SO IT BEHOOVES US TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ASSIST
SENIORS SO THAT THEY CAN AGE AN
AGE WITH DIGNITY IN THEIR OWN
HOMES.
SECOND THIS MEASURE ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
DURING THE NEXT TRIENNIAL
BUILDING STANDARDS RULEMAKING
CYCLE. TO DEVELOP AND PROPOSE
FOR ADOPTION BY THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION'S.
BUILT THE BUILT COMMISSION
EXCUSE ME BUILDING STANDARDS
REQUIRING FALL PREVENTION
STRUCTURAL FEATURES TO BE IN
PLACE. FOR SINGLE AND MULTI
FAMILY DWELLINGS TO PREVENT
FALLS AND TO FACILITATE AGING IN
PLACE THESE FEATURES COULD
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE ONE GROUND
LEVEL ENTRY WIDE INTERIOR DOORS.
ADEQUATE SPACE IN BATHROOMS AND
KITCHENS FOR MANEUVERABILITY OF
CHAIRS FOR EXAMPLE BLOCKING IN
BATHROOMS TO ALLOW FUTURE GRAB
BAR INSTALLATION.
REACHABLE ELECTRIC CONTROLS AND
A STEP FREE PATH THROUGH THE
ENTIRE GROUND FLOOR.
SIMPLE MEASURES LIKE THIS WHICH
SHOULD AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO AGE WE WILL BE ABLE TO USE TO
HELP PEOPLE PREVENT THOSE FALLS
IN THE EXTRAORDINARY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM IN FACT IN
THE UNITED STATES TODAY IT'S
ESTIMATED.
THAT WE SPEND FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR ADDRESSING WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN SENIORS FALL IN
THIS COUNTRY WE CAN DO BETTER.
AND IT IS MY HOPE THAT AS WE
MOVE THIS.
LEGISLATION FORWARD WE ARE ABLE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT A STITCH IN
TIME.
DOES INDEED SAVE NINE AND WITH
ME TODAY ISSAND WARREN
REPRESENTING THE BILL'S SPONSOR
THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE.
AS WELL AS MAXINE MAN TELL FROM
THE NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
ASSOCIATION EXCUSE ME SOCIETY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A MAN WARREN.
AND I AM.
OF SUBSTITUTING FOR THE AUTHOR.
OF THIS BILL.
WHO HAD TO BE OUT OF TOWN SO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT I MAKE?
ARE HER COMMENTS BUT I AGREE
WITH THEM WHOLEHEARTEDLY -- SHE
SAYS THAT HER OWN PASSION. FOR
ADD UP ADVOCATING FOR FAILS TO
FALL SAFE HOUSING STEMS FROM HER
EXPERIENCE.
WITH HER STEP MOTHER.
WHO SHATTERED HER FEMUR AS A
RESULT OF A FALL HE HAD TO STAY
IN THE NURSING HOME AND TOLD HER
LEG WAS FULLY RECOVERED? FOR
MANY MONTHS AS OUR HOUSE COULD
NOT ACCOMMODATE HER.
IN A WHEELCHAIR.
HER HUSBAND WAS UNABLE TO CARE
FOR HER IN THE HOME.
AND AS THE WHEELCHAIR COULD NOT
FIT THROUGH ANY OF THE DOORS
INSIDE OR OUTSIDE.
SHE WAS NOT ABLE TO VISIT
FRIENDS WHO USE WHEELCHAIRS INTO
HER HOME TO VISIT.
THUS MAKING HER MORE ISOLATED.
GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S NEED TO DROP
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE AVAILABLE
HOUSING THIS IS THE PERFECT TIME
FOR THE STATE TO MAKE THAT
HOUSING.
MORE AGE AND DISABILITY FRIENDLY.
BY INCORPORATING FALLS
PREVENTION OR SPECIFIC
ACCESSIBLE FEATURES INTO THE
STATE BUILDING STANDARDS. FOR
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING.
MAKING THESE CHANGES WILL ALLOW
RESIDENTS TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES
AS THEY AGE.
AND ALLOWS FAMILIES TO EASILY
BRING ELDER MEMBERS INTO THEIR
HOME.
AS THEY NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
AS I LOOK AROUND MY COMMUNITY I
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
[inaudible]
AND THE NEIGHBORHOOD THAT I LIVE
IN IS MULTI GENERATIONAL.
THERE ARE SENIORS WHO BOUGHT THE
HOUSE.
AND NOW THE CHILDREN HAVE MOVED
IN BECAUSE THE SENIORS CAN NO
LONGER LIVE THERE ALONE.
THAT IS THE REALITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I DO BELIEVE.
FALL SAFETY FEATURES CAN EASILY
COST LESS LOOK.
ACROSS MUCH LESS COSTLY WHEN
BUILT IN THE ORIGINAL DESIGN OF
THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AN INDIVIDUAL HOMES RATHER THAN
RETROFITTING.
I WAS LOOKING AT MY OWN HOME
THIS MORNING.
AND WONDERING HOW COULD WE RETRO
FIT MY HOUSE.
SO THAT I COULD STAY IN IT AND I
NOTICED THAT THERE WERE SOME
THINGS THAT COULD BE.
PUT INTO THE BUILDING STANDARDS
LIKE.
WHEN WE BUILD THE OPENING FOR
THE BATHROOMS LET'S SAY?
THEIR STANDARD BATHROOM SIZE
HOWEVER WE COULD INCREASE THIS
THE WIDTH OF IT.
OR AT LEAST LEAST GIVE.
US GIVE ME SOME [inaudible]
A SPACE ON THE SIDE OF THE DOOR.
THAT IT COULD BE EXPANDED AND WE
COULD MAKE IT WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBLE -- BUT IF WE START
NOW AS THE HOUSING IS BEING
BUILT.
AND MORE HOUSING IS BEING BUILT.
AS A RESULT OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS THIS IS THE TIME TO PUT
IT IN ACTION.
I KNOW IN SAN FRANCISCO THEY
WILL BE.
INTRODUCING A BOND TO BUILD
SENIOR HOUSING BUT THEY'RE ALSO
BUILDING OTHER HOUSING AND WE
WANT TO MAKE ALL HOUSING
AVAILABLE FOR SENIORS AS THEY
AGE.
WE ASK THAT YOU DO APPROVE THIS
BILL AND VOTED TO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MAXINE MAN
TALENT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL.
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY ESPY
TWO EIGHTY IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
FOR PEOPLE DISABLED WITH
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS.
MS IS A CHRONIC AN AWFUL AND
OFTEN DISABLING DISEASE OF THE
CENTRAL NERVOUS SYSTEM.
THAT TYPICALLY IS DIAGNOSED IN
YOUNG ADULTHOOD.
AND THIS IS A PUZZLING AND
UNPREDICTABLE DISEASE THAT
VARIES WIDELY IN ITS IMPACT NOT
ONLY FROM PERSON TO PERSON.
BUT ALSO IN THE SAME INDIVIDUAL
AT DIFFERENT TIMES.
MS CAN IMPAIR MUSCLE STRENGTH
SINCE SENSATION BALANCE
COORDINATION.
GATE AND CAUSE SIGNIFICANT
DISABLING DISEASE.
STUDIES CONSISTENTLY FIND THAT
OVER 50% OF PEOPLE WITH A MASS
HAVE FALLEN DOWN IN A THREE TO
SIX MONTH PERIOD.
AND 3250% HAVE FALLEN MULTIPLE
TIMES IN THAT SAME TIME PERIOD.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
ESTIMATES THAT FALLS ARE MOST
MOST THE MOST PREVENTABLE CAUSE
OF NURSING FACILITY PLACEMENT.
MODEST INVESTMENTS IN HOME
MODIFICATION CAN SAVE MONEY
INCREASED SAFETY IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY ALLOW PEOPLE WITH
MS TO MAINTAIN INDEPENDENCE IN
THEIR OWN HOME.
CONTINUE TO WORK AND BE ACTIVE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
WITHOUT SUCH MODIFICATIONS MANY
PEOPLE ARE FORCED TO MOVE AFTER
FALLS AND INJURIES.
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS SUCH AS GRAB
BARS AND SHOWERS ARE NEAR
TOILETS.
ALLOW CONTINUED INDEPENDENCE BY
AVOIDING ACCIDENTS THAT LEAD TO
INJURIES AND HOSPITAL STAYS.
THE INVESTMENT AND OTHER
MODIFICATIONS SUCH AS RAMPS AT
ENTRANCE DOORS.
GRAB RAILS LONG STAYERS RAISE
TOILETS AND LOWERED LIGHT
SWITCHES ALLOWS A DISABLED
INDIVIDUAL CONTINUED
INDEPENDENCE AND SAVES MONEY IN
THE LONG RUN.
BY ALLOWING PEOPLE TO AGE IN
PLACE.
THE COST OF MODIFYING A HOME TO
MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE VARIES WIDELY.
THIS GRANT PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE FALL PREVENTION BUILDING
STANDARDS ESTABLISHED THREE
SENATE BILL.
TWO EIGHTY WILL PROVIDE VALUABLE
VALUABLE ASSISTANCE AND
ENHANCING ACCESSIBILITY.
AND KEEPING PEOPLE WITH MS AND
OTHER DISABILITY SAFE IN THEIR
HOMES.
THE NATIONAL MS SOCIETY URGES
YOU TO SUPPORT SB.
TWO EIGHTY I'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD
AND ESTABLISH A CORN CAN WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MADONNA HI FOR TITLE HERE.
STONE.
DOWN HERE BELL.
BELL HERE JACKSON.
JACKSON HERE PAN.
AND HERE WINNER [inaudible]
WINNER HERE.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED CORN THANK
YOU.
SO DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE THIS
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS --
THESE TO BE AARON'S PART. THREE
SANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE ARC
IN UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION HERE IN
SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YES MADAM CHAIR ON BOB ROEMER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION A
AND WE HAVE -- SERIOUS CONCERNS
ONLY TWO WITH THE BUILDING
STANDARD PORTION OF THE BILL
FIRST I'D LIKE TO COVER WHAT WE
CAN'T SUPPORT -- WE'VE ALREADY
INFORMED EIGHT CD THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT THE LOWERING OF THE
LIGHT SWITCHES IN THE HVAC
CONTROLS.
IN ADDITION THE INSTALLATION OF
GRAB BARS SUPPORT BACKING IN ALL
OF THE BATHROOMS IN THE DWELLING
IS SOMETHING THAT CAN EASILY BE
DONE IT TIME TO CONSTRUCTION.
HOWEVER WE DO TAKE ISSUE WITH
THE REQUIREMENT FOR ALL INTERIOR
DOORS ARE TO BE ADE WIDER --
AND FOR THE CLEAR SPACE
REQUIREMENTS AND KITCHENS AND
BATHROOMS.
ARE THESE TWO ITEMS IN THE
COMBINATION WILL EFFECTIVELY
REQUIRES STAFF TO REDESIGN.
JUST ABOUT EVERY SINGLE FAMILY
PLAN THAT'S OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
WELL I WOULD ESTIMATE AT LEAST
95% OF THE PLANS THAT ARE
EXISTING TODAY WOULD HAVE TO BE
REDESIGNED.
ODD TO INCREASE THE THE WORST OF
THE DOOR -- MANAGE WHEN YOU GO
TO YOUR HOUSE THAT EACH YEAR
DOORS ARE NOW ABOUT SIX INCHES
WIDER THAT'S WHAT EACH CD WOULD
BE CALLING FOR IF THEY WENT
FORWARD WITH THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS.
THE RECORD AND APARTMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
EFFECTIVELY THAT'S GOING TO BE
EATING UP SPACE THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE FOR YOUR YOUR CLOSET -- IN
FOR THE CLEAR SPACE REQUIREMENTS
IN THE BATHROOMS AND KITCHENS
YOUR FACT WE GONNA HAVE TO BE
MOVING THE WALL OUT ABOUT TWO
FEET FROM WHERE IT IS NOW.
NOW THERE'S TWO WAYS TO COMPLY
WITH THIS REALLY THE HOW TO
INCREASE THE OVERALL SIZE OF THE
DWELLING UNIT BY ABOUT FORTY TO
FIFTY SQUARE FEET IN TOTAL.
WAR YOU'LL HAVE TO SIMPLY TAKE
THE AREA OUT OF THE MORE
MARKETABLE AREAS IN THE HOUSE IT
CLOSETS BATHROOMS -- AND I'M
SORRY CLOSET SAW AND BEDROOMS.
SO WE PLAN TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR -- WE WERE JUST
NOTIFIED THAT THIS BILL MAY BE
UP AS SOON AS NEXT TUESDAY AND
SENATE HOUSING -- WE'RE TRYING
TO DEVELOP SOME SORT OF
AMENDMENTS TO PROPOSE TO THE
AUTHOR AND TO SEND A HOUSING
COMMITTEE STAFF -- BUT THREE OR
FOUR DAYS IS VERY LITTLE TIME TO
DO THAT ANYWAY IF YOU'VE GOT ANY
QUESTIONS I CAN.
PROVIDE ANSWERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION IN THE AUDIENCE.
THREE NINE DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. FOR FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THUNDERSTORMS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
THE SENATOR JACKSON MAY I
CERTAINLY -- APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO -- 50% OF
SENIORS OF FALL BREAK THEIR HIP
HAVE A 50% MORTALITY RATE SO
IT'S IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE DO
WE CAN TRY TO AVOID FALLS.
I ALSO DABBLE LIKE REAL ESTATE I
LIKE GOING THROUGH NEW HOME
DEVELOPMENTS TO KIND OF SEE
WHAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON IS
AMAZING TO ME HOW MANY.
DEVELOPERS ALREADY INCORPORATING
A LOT OF COMMON SENSE --
IMPROVEMENTS SAID CERTAINLY ARE.
LESS EXPENSIVE IN THE FRONT AND
INSTEAD OF GOING BACK AND
RETROFITTING ON THE ON THE ON
THE BACK AND I SUPPORT.
VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING IN THE BILL
EXCEPT -- FALL PREVENTION
BUILDING STANDARDS -- IN MANY OF
THESE DEVELOMENTS THAT I GO SEE --
IF YOU WANNA HAVE WIDER DOORS
AND SMALLER CLOSETS AS A RESULT.
FOR IT -- IT'S USUALLY AN OPTION
THAT YOU CAN DO -- THE BUILDING
ENTRIES MENTIONED THEY HAVE TO
GO BACK AND AND REDO ALL OF
THEIR PLANS AND SOMETHING'S GOT
TO GIVE THE ONE THING THAT WON'T.
GO DOWN AS THE PRICE AND WE'RE
FACING AN AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
HERE IN.
IN CALIFORNIA AND WALL IT BE
GREAT TO SAY THAT WE COULD HAVE
ALL THESE IMPROVEMENTS IN STOCK
AND ADDED ADD TO THE COST OF
HOMES.
I'M A REALIST AND KNOW THAT IT
WILL INCREASE THE PRICE OF HOMES.
AND IT'S OKAY IF SOMEBODY'S
WILLING TO PAY IT AND AND WANTS
TO HAVE THESE PORTABILITY
OPTIONS FOR THEM AS THEY AGE OR
WHEN THEY SELL THEIR HOUSE THEY
SOUGHT TO AN AGED COUPLE -- BUT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT ALL OF US
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE HIGH
COST OF HOUSING THE MOST
EXPENSIVE PRETTY MUCH IN THE
CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES AND
I'M WORRIED THAT THIS WILL HAVE
AN EFFECT ON THAT SO -- ARE YOU
ARE YOU WILLING TO TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION ON THIS AND I'M
ALWAYS WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO BILL WHICH HAS GOT
IT -- SOMETIME LAST WEEK AND OF
COURSE -- HAPPY TO TO TRY TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS NO ONE WANTS TO
MAKE THE COST OF HOUSING MORE
EXPENSIVE PART OF WHAT WE WERE
THINKING OF AND IF I MAY.
US SENATOR OF MY HUSBAND I
BOUGHT OUR HOUSE THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO.
LITTLE DID WE EXPECT THAT THAT
AT SOME POINT IN TIME WE WOULD
WANT TO OR NEED TO PUT  GRAB
BAR.
I INTO THE SHOWER -- WHICH WE
DID ABOUT A YEAR AGO AND MY
HUSBAND WHO IS NOW THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OLDER THAN HE WAS WHEN WE
BOUGHT OUR HOUSE.
AND FELL AND COMPLETELY TOWARDS
ROTATOR CUFF.
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE THE
VISITS THE REHABILITATION -- I
THINK IT'S RUINED HIS GOLF GAME
BUT PROBABLY THAT WAS GOT LONG
GONE BEFORE HIS ROTATOR CUFF
PROBLEMS.
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY IF WE CAN BE
PREPARED AND ANTICIPATE TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN DO IT REASONABLY
AND LOGICALLY SO THE BASICALLY
ALL NEED THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE
WAS.
TO HAVE IN THE SHOWER THE
ABILITY AT SOME POINT IN TIME
THE WAY YOU GET THE HOUSE TO TO
BE CONSTRUCTED.
OUT WOULD ALLOW FOR THAT GRAB
BAR IF IF APPROPRIATE OR
NECESSARY AND THAT'S BASICALLY
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS THAT
WE AS WE AS WE BUILD NEW HOUSING
WE KEEP KEEP IN MIND.
THAT AT SOME POINT IN TIME GOD
FOR BID WE HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER
WHO.
SUFFERS FROM MS FOR SOME --
DEBILITATING A SITUATION THAT
REQUIRES THEM.
TO BE -- TRANSPORTED IN A CHAIR
FOR EXAMPLE JUST TO HAVE THOSE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE AT THE BOTTOM
THE MOST OPPORTUNE PRICE
POSSIBLE SO CERTAINLY I
APPRECIATE THAT THE OPPOSITION --
SEES THE THE GOOD INTENTIONS IN
THE POSITIVE ASPECTS OF THIS AND
WE'RE CERTAINLY I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM TO SEE
IF WE CAN'T COME TO EAT AND EVEN
BETTER.
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
DO BECAUSE THE GOAL AGAIN WHEN
IT COST FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AS YOU MENTION 50%
THOSE PEOPLE FALL THEY NEVER
RECOVER.
OR THEY END UP IN THE HOUSE --
INSTITUTIONAL CARE WHERE EITHER
MEDICARE OUR MEDICARE IS PAYING
FOR IT GRAB BARKING COOKING --
COST AS LITTLE AS A FEW HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
THOUSANDS THAT IT'S SAFE TO SAY
NOTHING OF THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO SUFFER FROM
THOSE EVENTS IN AS YOU KNOW
BEING SOMEONE WHO'S VERY ACUTELY
AWARE IN THE MEDICAL FIELD YOU
DON'T.
WE LOSE OUR BALANCE A AS WE AGE
AND THESE KINDS OF THINGS BECOME
MORE AND MORE PREVALENT SO HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THEM APPRECIATE
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO DO SO AS
WELL ONE PRESHEAF THAT AND
OWNING A LOT OF SENIOR ONLY --
UNITS MYSELF -- I OCCASIONALLY
GET SENIORS TO COME IN AND SAY
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO LISA'S
PLACE FOR ME ABOUT.
WE SURE LIKE I'VE GRAB BARS YOU
KNOW IN THE SHOWERS OF THE
BATHTUB SINCE.
DYSLEXIA IS ABOUT A HUNDRED
BUCKS I MEAN IS IT'S REALLY
INEXPENSIVE TO PUT THE MAN EVEN.
YOU KNOW WITHOUT HAVING THEM AS
A PART OF A MANDATE TO PUT A MAN
WHEN YOU'RE BUILDING A BRAND NEW
HOME SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITHTHE MONGOLS
SUPPORTED TODAY UNTIL I SEE THAT
THERE'S SOME -- AGREEMENT --
WITH OUR BUILDING STANDARDS BUT
I I I DO APPRECIATE THE SCOPE
AND ANGLE OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO.
IT AGAIN IF I MADE THE THE
NOTION IS YOU DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO PUT THE GRAB BAR IN
IMMEDIATELY INTEREST THAT THE
STRUCTURE OF THE HOUSE HAS TO
ACCOMMODATE IT.
IF YOU DO AT SOME POINT DECIDE
TO PUT ONE IN.
THANK YOU -- AND I THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON FOR FOR BRING
THIS FORD I KNOW THAT TO YOU WE
HAD TALKED ABOUT LAST YEAR ABOUT --
THE IN THE BUDGET AS WELL --
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE ISSUES
OF THE EMPLOYEE GRAB BARS AND
OTHER TYPES OF DEVICES WHICH
REALLY DO -- BUT SAVE MONEY AND
SAVE LIVES AND ACTUALLY
INTERESTED I'D APPRECIATE US ARE
SEWN BRING UP THAT STUDY
ACTUALLY WORKED ON AT LEAST I
KNOW IT WAS THAT SPECIFIC STUDY.
BUT A STUDY THAT ACTUALLY SHOW
THAT WAS THE FIRST TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE FALLS THAT
LEAD TO HAVE FRACTURES THE TIMER
TOLERATE WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE
WAY BACK THEN.
SO I ACTUALLY DID SOME RESEARCH
YEAH A LONG TIME AGO BUT I DID
RESEARCH AND JERRY AT IN
GERIATRICS -- BEFORE I WENT TO
PEDIATRICS OF MEDICINE -- SO THE
SERVER SO I THINK YOU KNOW I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL
ANDWHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH -- AND GENTLY
SUPPORTED I DO HOPE YOU DO WORK
WITH THE BUILDING FOLKS IT IS
PROBABLY MORE OF AN ISSUE I
GUESS THE HOUSING AND I THINK
CENTER WINNER I'M SURE WILL.
WEIGH IN ON THAT TWENTY GETS TO
THAT POINT -- I I I I THINK I DO
SHARE SOME OF THEIR STONES
CONCERNS ABOUT -- I'VE I THINK
THAT THE DEGREE THAT WE CAN MAKE
THE HOUSE READY -- FOR FOR SOME
PEOPLE IN AGING PLACE I THINK
IT'S A GOOD THING -- YOU MIGHT
HEAR FORTY SQUARE ADDITIONAL
FORTY SQUARE FEET FEET -- THAT
HAS TO BE ADDED TO THE HOUSE YOU
KNOW IF THEY MAKE WIDER HALLWAYS
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS -- AND
THEN I START THINKING WELL IF
IT'S A TWO STORY HOUSE FOR ONE
STORY HOUSE HOW MUCH BENEFIT
WE'RE REALLY GETTING YOU KNOW WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO HAVE THINGS
THAT BUT AND COST THAT MIGHT BE
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT -- YOUNG
LADY THANK WHETHER THERE'S A S.
MARS NOT THE RIGHT WORD -- BUT
YOU KNOW SOME THINK ABOUT THE
REALLY WHAT THE TRADEOFFS ARE
AND ENTER AND TERMS OF THAT BUT
CERTAINLY I THINK.
MAKING A GRAB BAR READY AND BE
ABLE TO HAVE MONEY TO HELP
PEOPLE GET GRAB BARS AND OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS AND AND SOME
MAIL PHONY THE SLICE WITH ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE
FAIRLY I THINK.
SIMPLY AND BUT WOULD BE SOME
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE WANT AS
OUR STATE IS AGING SO -- I WANT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRAINS
BUILT FORD AND BE HAPPY TO MOVE
AT THE PROPER TIME.
THANK YOU US UNDER JACK.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BUT JUST
BRIEFLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AGAIN THE GOAL IS NOT
TO INCREASE THE COST.
OF HOUSING BUT TO MAKE IT.
MORE ACCESSIBLE AS WE AGE AND IF
WE'RE SO LUCKY AS TO BE LIVING
IN THE SAME HOME.
WE BOUGHT WHEN WE WERE YOUNG AND
FOOLISH AND WHEN WE GET OLDER
AND GRAYER -- CERTAINLY I THINK
THAT THAT IS THE ULTIMATE GOAL
AND AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION IS
TO COME TO SOME.
US FOR A CONSENSUS ON THE BEST
WAY TO PROCEED WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON --
CENTER PAN HAS MOVED THE BILL.
THE MOTION IS -- TO THAT. TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SEND A
HOUSING COMMITTEE SP TWO EIGHT
ZERO SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HER TITLE HI -- HER TITLE I
DON'T KNOW STONE NO.
BELL.
BELL I JACKSON JACKSON I PAN.
PAN HI WINNER WINNER HIGH
[inaudible] FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
I HAVE FIVE ONE FIVE ONE PM.
THE VOTE IS.
FIVE ONE THE BILL IS OUT.
NOW WE HAVE SENATOR HERTZBERG'S
SP FIVE TWO FIVE EIGHT I'M SORRY.
HERE TO PRESENT WELCOME SENATOR
HURTS PARK.
AND TO YOUR WITNESSES -- WE ASK
THAT THE WITNESS OF KEEP THEIR
TESTIMONY TWO TO THREE MINUTES
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MADAM
CHAIR.
YOU KNOW.
ONE OUR GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
DEALING FOR SOME TIME IN MANY
RESPECTS.
ON THE ISSUE OF PEOPLE WHO FIND
THEMSELVES HOMELESS.
WITH THE COMMITTEE HEARING SON
DURING THE INTERIM.
CAN'T RECALL THE COMMITTEE I WON
THE TENDED.
AND THAT WAS SEVENTY SIX
PROGRAMS IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
FOR HOMES.
OF SOME SORT.
IN LOS ANGELES WE PASSED MEASURE
HHH THE COUNTY H. CITY.
WE JUST PASSED THE STEINBERG --
IT DEAL A FEW BILLION DOLLARS
FOR PEOPLE WHO FIND THEMSELVES
HOMELESS OF MENTAL ISSUES. FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS RECENTLY ON A
BOND ISSUE I THINK CENTER BELLS
ISSUE WAS THAT.
WE HAD FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR AND WE HAVE
MONEY MONEY MONEY. FOR ALL SORTS
OF THINGS BUT THE REALITY IS IN
THE FRUSTRATION THAT I HAVE
EXPERIENCED HAS.
HOW DO YOU TRANSLATE NOT ACTION
WHEN I GO IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT I REPRESENT?
PEOPLE ARE ANGRY.
YOU'RE SAYING JUST YOU PUT WE'RE
VOTING FOR ALL THE STUFF WE HAVE
SAID WE WILL INCREASE OUR TAXES
WE WILL AUTHORIZE BONDS WILL DO
ALL THIS STUFF.
AND WHAT IS TRANSPIRING.
AND SO I BEGAN TO FOCUS ON ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO IN
THE HUMAN CONDITION BROADLY
SPEAKING.
IF YOU WILL -- THAT IMPACT
PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT CAN IMPACT
THE PRICE OF THE THE ISSUE OF
PEOPLE FIND THEMSELVES HOMELESS
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE ATTACKS
AND WINNER DURING THE BREAK ON
THIS A LITTLE BIT I THINK.
MEMBER CORRECTLY.
AND ARM WHAT WE FOUND IN THE
COMMUNITY IS I WAS TRAVELING
THROUGH ALL THE NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCILS AND TALKING TO FOLKS
WHO FOUND THEMSELVES HOMELESS
WAS.
AS WAS SUGGESTED TO ME ELEGANTLY.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GO OUT AND
DO A SHELTER LEAVE THEIR BEST
FRIEND ON THE STREET.
AND SOMETIMES OUR BEST FRIENDS.
AND SO THE IDEA HERE WAS TO
START OUT WITH A I MEAN I'VE
EVERY NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL EVERY
PLACE IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
THIS IS.
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY GETS A
AND IT'S YOU KNOW IN LOS ANGELES
I'M TOLD.
THAT IT COULD BE AS HIGH AS 25%
OF PEOPLE WITH PETS SO HERE WE
ARE IN IN LA COUNTY GOT 22% FOR
SOME FACILITIES ON MICE WITH 22%
WITH OPEN BEDS BECAUSE PEOPLE
WON'T GO BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT TO
LEAVE THEIR BEST FRIEND ON THE
STREETS.
AND SO THIS IS THE FIRST STEP OF
PUTTING FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
LIKE YOU TO MAKE A LOT BIGGER
QUITE FRANKLY HAVE A GRANT
PROGRAM ACCEPTING YOUR MEMBERS
JUST WHERE THE MONEY IS TO GO.
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
AND AVAILABILITY OF PEOPLE WHEN
THEY GO IN -- TO THESE
FACILITIES THEY CAN BRING THEIR
PETS WITH THEM AND OFTEN IT
BEGINS TO HELP THEM AS I'M TOLD
TO GET OFF THE MARK STREET AS
THEY CAN GET SERVICES FOR THEIR
PETS THEY CAN ALSO HELP
THEMSELVES.
IN THAT REGARD AND IT'S OKAY
QUITE FRANKLY JUST CONSIDERING
THE BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE'VE AUTHORIZED.
GENERAL FUNDS DOLLARS THAT WE'VE
AUTHORIZED.
AND NEW TAXES THAT WE'VE
AUTHORIZED THIS TO ME IS
SOMETHING THAT -- YOU KNOW AS WE
IS IS IS IS BOTH ENDS OF THE
LEASH KIND OF A OF A BILL AND
I'MJUST REALLY PROUD OF IT IT'S
NOT A GIGANTIC NUMBER BY ORDERS
OF MAGNITUDE BUT I THINK GIVEN
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE FACING
FOR PEOPLE TO FIND THEMSELVES
HOMELESS IS.
IT IS THE RIGHT APPROPRIATE
THING TO DO WITH THIS I WILL
TURN THIS OVER TO MY WITNESSES
WHOEVER WANTS TO START FIRST.
FIRST I'LL GO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GINA
NAP BUT I MANAGE THE FRONT ST
ANIMAL SHELTER FOR THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO -- TODAY TO URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THAT BILL TO FIFTY
EIGHT THE HUMAN ANIMAL BOND IS
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL.
AND IF YOU HAVE PETS THINK ABOUT
THEM RIGHT NOW.
ACCORDING TO THE NEW ENGLAND
JOURNAL OF MEDICINE THAT POP
REPORT WAS PUBLISHED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN THAT
STATED THAT THE LOSS OF A
BELOVED PET CAN IMPAIR OUR
EMOTIONAL.
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH OFTEN TIMES
WORSE FOR THE LOSS OF A SPOUSE
WHICH I FOUND PRETTY AMAZING.
WHETHER YOU LIVE IN A HOUSE OR
YOU LIVE IN A TENT ALONG THE
AMERICAN RIVER.
MAKES NO DIFFERENCE YOUR BOND
AND YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR
PAT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT DIFFERENT
AND I CAN ATTEST TO THAT FIRST
HAND.
BONDS OFTEN EVEN STRONGER FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
NOT JUST COMPANIONSHIP AND
PROTECTION.
BUT PURPOSE -- SOMETHING TO LIVE
FOR AND SOMETHING TO CARE.
FOR AND I'VE HEARD IT OVER AND
OVER IF I DIDN'T HAVE MY PAT I
DON'T THINK I COULD SURVIVE ON
THE STREET -- IT IS A REASON TO
GO ON LIVING FOR THEM IN MANY
CASES.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN I'M
SPENDING BACK TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WHEN I FIRST TOOK THIS
POSITION I'M JUST LOOKING AT TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THE FRENCH
REDOUBTABLE SHELTER HAS INVESTED
THROUGH GENERAL FIND GRANTS
FUNDRAISING.
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS JUST THIS LAST YEAR ON
PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS CRATES
FOOD LEASHES EVEN SOME BEHAVIOR
TRAINING SO PETS CAN BE COULD
COMPANION STAYED AND PREVENT
BEING A BARRIER FROM HOUSING --
THAT WAS JUST AT THE WINNER
TRIAGE SHELTER UP ON RAILROAD
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE OUR LABOR
COSTS.
DOES NOT INCLUDE -- THOSE
ANIMALS THAT CAME TO US AND HAD
TO BE IMPOUNDED BECAUSE THEIR
OWNERS WERE EITHER HOSPITALIZED
OR INCARCERATED WHICH HAPPENS
FREQUENTLY.
THE THESE ARE THE ANIMALS THAT
ARE MOST AT RISK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO END UP IN OUR
SHELTER.
I CAN ATTEST FIRST HAND AGAIN
PEOPLE REFUSE MEDICAL AID IF IT
MEANS THEY HAVE TO GIVE UP THEIR
PETS.
LITERALLY WILLING TO DIE --
BEFORE THEY LEAVE THEIR ANIMALS
OFTEN THEIR ANIMALS EAT BEFORE
THEY DO.
WE ALL KNOW HOME IS AS AS AN
EPIDEMIC THE EPIDEMIC WOULD DO.
THAT -- ENDS OF THE LEASE WHICH
I CLAIMED I DON'T KNOW WHO STOLE
THAT PHRASE INTO ME.
BUT THE NEED IS REAL AND THE
RESULTS COULD POTENTIALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU A TEAR WOMEN ARE
HOTTER MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY
NAME IS JANET HENDRICKSON I'M A
LICENSED NURSE PRACTITIONER I
ALSO HAPPEN TO HAVE THE LICENSE
OF THE POSITION ASSISTANT.
I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT AND
FOUNDER OF CHANGING THE STREETS
WE ARE A SACRAMENTO BASED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
WHOSE MISSION IS HELP
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
THROUGH HEALTHCARE IN THE WHAT
SPIRIT OF THE ONE HEALTH
INITIATIVE THE ONE HEALTH
INITIATIVE.
IS A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH. TO
LOOKING AT MULTIPLE PROFESSIONS
WORKING TOGETHER TO DELIVER
HEALTHCARE.
LOOKING AT HOW ANIMALS.
PEOPLE AND THE ENVIRONMENT ALL
WORK TOGETHER.
OUR FIRST PROJECT THAT WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING IS A COLLABORATION
WITH A FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTER ONE COMMUNITY
HEALTH LOCATED MIDTOWN
SACRAMENTO.
AND WIND YOU SERVICES WE HOLD A
MONTHLY VETERINARY CLINIC WHEN I
ALSO DELIVER HUMAN HEALTH CARE
AT THE SAME TIME THROUGH THESE
CLINICS.
AND ALSO THE PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER IN MY PAST AS AT FQHCS.
AND EVEN WHEN I WORKED IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT THE PRIMER
AS A PROVIDER I COULD SEE THE
BOND BETWEEN PEOPLE IN THEIR
ANIMALS.
MANY OF MY PATIENTS HAVE TOLD ME
THAT THEY OFFER GONE THEIR
MEDICATIONS THEIR FOOD AND THEY
HAVE DEFINITELY TURNED DOWN A
PLACE TO LIVE.
BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT TAKE
THEIR ANIMAL OR ANIMAL WAS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING TO THEM.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL --
YOUR YES VOTE THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW OPEN FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE BILL IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE LAST EXPRESS GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- JENNIFER FEARING I'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY FIRST ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF AS A MEMBER OF THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL I'M SO
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE SUCH
LEADERS IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT
SACRAMENTO IS SETTING SUCH A
HIGH BAR AND STANDARD.
ON THIS ISSUE IN THAT SENATOR
HERTZBERG HAS SEEN THE WISDOM OF
TAKING THAT MAKING FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR OTHERS IN THE
STATE.
BUT I'M ALSO FORTUNATE TO HAVE
CLIENTS IN THE BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY SAN DIEGO HUMANE
SOCIETY AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
SPCA THAT ALSO URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
POETRY POLITICS ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY SUPPORT FOR OUR
LOCAL SHELTER -- I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MEDICINE
DAHLIA BEHALF OF MARS
INCORPORATED A MARS PET CARE AND
SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS SACKETT UP REPRESENTING
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION
AND SUPPORT.
IN ADDITIONAL ARE.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO COME FORWARD.
ONCE IN A NO BRAINER.
OKAY TWO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
THE OTHER [inaudible]
USE OF YEAH CHRIS FIRST THANK
YOU -- AS IN ALL DIFFERENT MIGHT
MIGHT MY COLLEAGUES -- CENTERS
FOR YOU YOU YOU MENTIONED THAT.
FOR MANY THESE HOMELESS --
PEOPLE HOW COME THE FORGOTTEN
PEOPLE.
THAT -- THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
LEAVE THEIR BEST FRIEND --
BEHIND.
AND FOR MANY OF THEM IT'S NOT
JUST THEIR BEST FRIEND IS THEIR
ONLY RELATIVE.
IS THE ONLY LOVE THAT THEY
EXPERIENCE IN A VERY CRUEL COLD
WORLD.
AND I SEE -- IN MY DISTRICT
CERTAINLY WERE -- WE HAVE A
HOMELESS PROBLEM JUST LIKE
EVERYWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE --
THAT.
MANY PROBABLY ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
OR 30% AS WAS MENTIONED I HAVE
PETS AND THEY TAKE CARE OF THE
PETS BEFORE THEY EVEN TAKE CARE
OF THEMSELVES.
SO THIS IS IT IS A BEAUTIFUL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND I'M
HAPPY THAT YOU'RE BRINGING A
FOREIGN I'M PRETTY IMPRESSED IN.
WITH WHAT YOU'RE DOING IT IN
SACRAMENTO THAT'S GONNA SET I
THINK OF A MODEL. FOR FOR THE
STATE AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA
SEE MORE PEOPLE GET HOUSING --
WITH INCORPORATING OF THIS
FUNDING SO THAT THEIR THEIR
CANINE OR FELINE COME --
COMPANIONS CAN CAN CAN BE CAN BE
WITH THEM AND SO IF THE PROPER
TIME I LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
USERS FROM SENATOR WINNING.
THANK YOU ROGER THANK YOU THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I'D I SHOULD INTEREST IN BEING
CO AUTHOR.
ON AND I AS YOU KNOW WE DID --
SOMETIMES SIT DOWN AND SPEAK
ABOUT THIS AND I I MEAN THIS IS
A GREAT AND AS WE ALSO DISCUSS
I'VE -- BILL -- MYSTERY -- FORTY
EIGHT THAT -- SETS -- STANDARDS
FOR HOMELESS SHELTERS AND ONE OF
THEM IS TO START MOVING THE
ENTIRE SHELTER SYSTEM.
TOWARDS BEING MORE -- PET
FRIENDLY -- BECAUSE YOU'RE A
100% RIGHT IT'S IT'S ONE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS THAT WE SEE
IN HELPING GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS.
BY IN THE SHELTER SO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER --
HOPEFULLY THIS CAN BOTH MOVE
FORWARD AND WE CAN -- MAKE SOME
REAL CHANGE THANK THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS FOR YOUR KINDNESS.
AND JACKSON IS THANK YOU ARE HI
I WANT TO PREFACE THIS BY SAYING
I'M A LIFETIME.
DOG OWNER I UNDERSTAND THIS
COMPLETELY MY ONLY CONCERN.
IS -- HOW WE CAN GO ABOUT DOING
THIS BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE HOMELESS DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO CARE FOR THEIR
ANIMALS TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
MEDICAL TREATMENT TO THE THE?
VACCINATIONS THE CARROT SET FOR
AND MY MY CONCERN IS THAT THEY
COME INTO SHELTER IN THE ANIMAL
HAS
YOU KNOW SOME KIND OF CONDITION
THAT IS POTENTIALLY TRANSFERABLE --
IS THERE IS THERE IS SOME
PROTOCOL THAT THAT CAN BE
DEVELOPED SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT.
IF PEOPLE BRING THEIR ANIMALS IN
AND THEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO
BRINGS IN A SICK ANIMAL THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO TRANSFER
TRANSMIT THAT IT.
THAT ILLNESS TO THE OTHER
ANIMALS THERE BECAUSE THAT'S THE
QUICKEST WAY TO GET PEOPLE TO
SAY FORGET IT I'D RATHER BE ON
THE STREET SO.
IN THIS PROGRAM IS THERE SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW YOU GONNA
GO ABOUT MAKING SURE FIRST OF
ALL AN OPPORTUNITY GET THESE
ANIMALS FOOD MEDICAL CARE THAT
THEY NEED TO HAVE ANYWAY -- OR
SHOULD HAVE BUT DO IT IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE OTHER ANIMALS
WHO MIGHT BE IN THE SHELTER
THANK YOU SENATOR THAT'S EXACTLY
CORRECT. TO QUALIFY FOR A GRANT
TO SUCH A SHELTER MUST HAVE
THREE THINGS FIRST.
SHELTER FOOD AND BASIC
VETERINARY SERVICES FOR PETS OF
THE HOMELESS OF THE PEOPLE THAT
FIND THEMSELVES HOMELESS TO
SHELTERS MUST ESTABLISH YOUR
PHARMACIST IS RULES OF CONDUCT
RESPONSIBILITY REGARDING PETS
AND THEIR OWNERS.
CREATING -- KENNELLY EITHER
BUNKS OR IN SEPARATE AREAS AND
FOOD FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCES
HOMELESSNESS WITH ANIMALS AND
THREE SHELTERS AND ALSO NEED TO
HAVE ACCESS TO A SHELTER THAT AN
OFFER SPAY AND NEUTER SERVICES
SO THE IDEA OF HAVING THE VAT.
AND THOSE SERVICES PART OF IT
WOULD BE THE REQUIREMENTS TO
QUALIFY FOR ONE OF THESE GRANTS
THEY WOULD APPLY.
FOR I GUESS MY ONLY CONCERN FOR
ME TO THE CHAIR IS SPAY AND
NEUTER VERY IMPORTANT BUT I'M
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT PETS WHO
MIGHT COME IN WITH SOME.
KIND OF COMMUNICABLE OR PROBLEM
THAT COULD RUN THROUGH THE
SHELTER SO IS THERE SO WHEN YOU
SAY GENERAL SERVICES.
CAN YOU MAYBE BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE SPECIFIC CHEST SO WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT WERE.
THAT THAT THESE ANIMALS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE -- EXPOSING OTHER
OTHER PATHS TO POTENTIAL SERIOUS
PROBLEMS THAT WE KNOW SOMETIMES
DUE TO I THINK I THINK WE COULD
PUSH MORE DEFINITION AROUND
ABOUT THE IDEA OF HOW REQUIRING
A SHELTER OF THAT OF HAVING OF
THAT THEY ARE TO BE EXAMINED THE
ANIMALS AND THE LIKE.
I ASSUME AS A RESULT OF THEIR
EXPERIENCES A VETERINARIAN WOULD
THEN MAKE THOSE DETERMINATIONS.
AS ANY GOOD MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
WOULD AND AND AND SORT OF THOSE
STANDARDS I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
MEAN BY SETTING UP THOSE
STANDARDS WITH THE WITH THE
SHELTER THAT.
I WOULD FEEL A LITTLE MORE
COMFORTABLE I'M GOING TO VOTE
FOR THE BILL BUT I'D FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE IF YOU COULD BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT
SORT OF THE HIGH HIDE ADDRESSING
THAT POTENTIAL PROBLEMS WITH IT
THAT IT.
IS COVERED IMMEDIATELY.
AND WITHOUT THE RISKS.
OF THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE.
TAKE PLACE WHICH I KNOW YOU
DON'T WANT BUT I JUST I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE INSTANCES A DOGLE
COMING WITH MANGE FOR EXAMPLE --
OR SOME CONDITION AND I THINK
THAT AS MUCH OF THIS IS A
SPECIFIC.
REQUIREMENT THAT WHOEVER'S GONNA
PROVISOS VETERINARY SERVICES IS
GOING TO LOOK ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
THAT THAT THESE ANIMALS WILL NOT
BE IN DANGER -- OR BE
TRANSMITTING POTENTIALLY DATE A
DANGERS ARE FATAL ILLNESSES TO
THE OTHER ANIMALS FOR PEOPLE IN
THE FACILITY.
I CAN SPEAK TO THAT WE OPEN THE
CITY OF SEGMENT OPEN THE WINTER
TRIAGE SHELTER THAT BECAME
WINTER SPRING SUMMER FALL AS YOU
ALL KNOW.
DECEMBER EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN AND SINCE THEN THERE
HAVE PROBABLY BEEN ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED ANIMALS GO THROUGH.
WE HAVE PROTOCOLS FOR CHECKING
IN SEATTLE'S FULLY VETTED
VACCINATED ONCE OVER DE WORMED
FLEA TREATED.
COMPLETELY VETTED WITH
VACCINATIONS AND WE MONITOR BI
WEEKLY TO MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
DISEASE THAT WE HAD IN ALL THAT
TIME SINCE THEN WHAT IS THAT
FOURTEEN MONTHS. FIFTEEN MONTHS --
ONE PUPPY WAS BROUGHT IN WITH
PART OF OUR OWN THAT WAS DEALT
WITH THE CLIENTS THEMSELVES THE
GUESTS ARE TRAINED TO LOOK FOR
DISEASE.
AND THEY'RE ALSO TRAINED HOW TO
APPROPRIATELY DISINFECT JUST
LIKE HER HEALTH IN AN ANIMAL
SHELTER SO I THINK THAT BE A
VERY EASY THING YUP TO
INCORPORATE GOOD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FENDER BASS.
THE USE THE DROP IN CENTERS IN --
SAN JOSE'S FROM BY THE BILL
WILSON CENTER AND FEW YEARS AGO --
WHEN I WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR --
I VISITED TO LOOK AT A PROGRAM
FOR YOUNG -- WOMEN THAT WERE RUN
AWAY USE HOMELESS OF LIVING ON
THE STREETS.
AND SO I GO OVER THERE AND AS I
WAS WALKING IN I NOTICED THERE
WAS -- DOGS -- TETHERED TO THE
POLLS AND I **** WHOSE DOGS ARE
THESE AND THEY SAID ALL THE
GIRLS OF DOGS. TO PROTECT THEM.
AND SO I WALK A LITTLE CLOSER
AND ACTUALLY ONE OF THE DOGS
CAME OUT AND BIT ME.
THIS IS TRUE STORY.
SO HE GETS MORE INTERESTING THE
THE I WENT TO THE YEAH I JUST.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THEY TOOK
CARE OF ME RIGHT AWAY AND THEN I
WENT AND TALKED TO THE GIRLS AND
LEARNED ABOUT THEIR WHAT THEY
WERE DOING.
AND THEY SAID THEY HAD THE DOGS
FOR PROTECTION BECAUSE THE HOLD.
THEY WERE KINDA GIGGLE LAYING
OUT OF THOUGHT WAS KIND OF FUNNY
THAT THE HE SAID THE BIG GUY WAS
BITTEN.
AND SO -- ABOUT FOUR FIVE YEARS
LATER -- I HAD A STUDENT INTERN
WHO IS -- GETTING HER DEGREE AT
THE SOCIAL WORK SCHOOL.
AS AS A STATE SHE WAS A GRADUATE
STUDENT DOING INTERNSHIP IN MY
OFFICE.
AND SHE SIGNED UP TO WORK ON THE
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM.
AND SHE SAYS WELL CENTER CENTER
I I I I WAS I THINK IT WAS THE
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME SHE SAID
ASSEMBLYMAN.
I I MET YOU BEFORE AND I GO
WHERE JIMMY MAN SHE SAYS MY DOG
****.
SO SHE WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
HOMELESS GIRL.
GREW UP GOT HER DEGREE AND YOU
SPOKE A FEW YEARS AGO AT THE
MASTERS IN SOCIAL WORK I GAVE
THE SPEECH AT HER GRADUATION.
SO I THINK -- IS NOW A SOCIAL
WORKER PRACTICING IN SAN JOSE SO
I I THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW THE
DOGS OR IMPORTANT ANGLE PART OF
THE SAFETY AND THE THERAPY I'D
SAY.
AND NOW THE HOMELESS ESPECIALLY
YOUNG WOMEN IN THE HOMELESS
POPULATION WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT
IT THAT WAY IT'S THIS DEFINITELY
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ABOUT THAT.
I THINK I WHAT I'M SAYING IS
PRETTY MUCH COMMON THROUGHOUT
THE CALIFORNIA BUT BUT IN HER
CASE IT WAS AN ESSENTIAL -- SHE
LIVED ON THE STREETS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS HAD A DOG PROTECTED -- AND
I THINK IT IT IT IT CREATED THAT
SURVIVAL SKILL ENOUGH TO GO OUT
AND LATER GET A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN SOCIAL WORK.
SO I I I SUPPORT THIS
[inaudible]
CENTER PAT.
THANK YOU AND FOR SO I JUST
WANNA RECOGNIZE -- THANK YOU MY
CONSTITUENTS LITTLE SACRAMENTO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR WORK AND I
KNOW MANY OF THE PEOPLE ALSO
TESTIFIED FAVOR.
AS WELL -- AND VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS BILL -- A YOU KNOW SHE
SHARED SOME OF I THINK
APPRECIATE THEIR JACKSON BRING
UP THE ISSUE ABOUT CONTAGIOUS
DISEASES MAYBE ONE OF THINGS WE
CAN DO IS -- GIVEN WHAT WE
REALLY KNOW SO EVERY SHELTERS
ARE BUILDING IT ON THEIR OWN I
REALIZE YOU DO HAVE HERE ABOUT
THAT NEW SERVICES SOME
GUIDELINES PERHAPS -- THAT COULD
GO OUT WITH WHATEVER GRANTS IN
TERMS OF WHAT SORT OF SCREENING
ITSELF WERE BASED ON BEST
PRACTICES IT'S GOING TO BE
TOMORROW COULD BE PART OF THAT.
AGAIN IT'S ABOUT THE SAFETY IN
THE SHELTER FOR THE PETS AS WELL
OF COURSE FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THERE THANK YOU WHAT WAS THIS
WANTED.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THIS IS.
IN YOUR ERA BOTH ENDS OF THE
LEASH BELL.
AND YOU KNOW I ON A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR BASIS IF IF IF I HAD THE
GUTS THAT MAKE THIS A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR.
ASK BECAUSE WE COULD QUITE
FRANKLY IF YOU LOOK AT IT THIS
IS 10% OF THE POPULATION OF
FOLKS WHO HAVE PETS AND WE CAN.
HELP THE SOLVE THE PROBLEM GAVE
BASED UPON HOW MUCH OTHER
RESOURCES WE SOLVE WHO CARES
WHAT THE SOLUTION IS.
DON'T FALL IN LOVE WITH THE
DON'T DON'T FALL IN LOVE WITH
THE WITH WITH YOUR SOLUTION FALL
IN LOVE WITH THE PROBLEMS AND WE
KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER THAT.
AND SO.
GOOGLE LEX AND SO WHAT WITH THAT
I'D LIKE -- TO A GOOD TALK BLAT
ON THE THE THE CENTER STONE AND
SENATOR WEINER ANYBODY ELSE
WANTS TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR
OF THIS MEASURE I'D LOVE TO HAVE
YOU AND ASK YOU I I'M GOOD THANK
YOU SAID ABOUT.
YEAH.
IS THERE A MOTION FOR THIS BILL.
OKAY DOWN THE LINE WINNER.
OKAY THE MOTION IS -- TO DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. FOR S.
B. TWO FIVE EIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HER TITLE.
HI HER TITLE I STONE.
STONE I BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
pAM WINNER.
WINNER HI.
SIX ZERO ABOUT A SIX ZERO THE
BILL AMOUNT -- SO WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO THE CONTENT
COUNTER WILL VOTE ON ON IT THE
ONLY ITEM ON CONSENT IS SP THREE
THREE THREE I WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE'S.
SECOND PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SB THREE THIRTY THREE
THIRTY THREE SENATOR WELCOME THE
MOTION IS DO PASS TO ATTACK.
IN A HOUSING WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT.
HER TITLE HI HER TITLE II STONE.
STONE I'D BELL RIGHT NOW I
JACKSON.
JACKSON A PEN.
PAN I WINNER.
WINNER I SIX ZERO SIX ZERO AND
BILL IS OUT.
AND THIS -- ENDS.
TODAY'S COMMITTEE HEARING ON THE
FOR HUMAN SERVICES THANK YOU SO
MUCH